antoine vous êtes sur place que faut-il
retenir dans les grandes lignes oui bien
je vous propose de revenir un petit peu
sur le message de bienvenue de vladimir
poutine qui a donc ouvert cette 9e
conférence internationale sur la
sécurité
à cette occasion il a fait savoir que la
russie développer une armée qui
répondait principalement à des objectifs
de défense et qu'il n'y avait pas de
recherche de but hégémonique à la
construction de cette armée mais bien
d'établir un équilibre au niveau mondial
ni plus ni moins il a également rappelé
son attachement au droit au droit
international et au dialogue
diplomatique même si quand il le faut la
russie c'est intervenir afin de
participer au règlement des conflits
régionaux il a entre autres évoqué
l'exemple de la syrie mais aussi du haut
karabakh dans lequel la russie dispose
d'une force de maintien de la paix enfin
il a évoqué l' escalade de l' escalade
militaire de l'otan aux frontières de la
russie
écoutez nous ne pouvons pas rester
indifférents à l'augmentation du
potentiel et des infrastructures de
l'otan à proximité des frontières de la
russie
surtout que l'otan refusent nous
proposition de désescalade et de
réduction des risques d'incidents a
prévu nous espérons que le bon sens et
le souhait de mener avec nous des
relations constructives domineront
finalement dans son message va dire
poutine a donc justifié expliquer les
axes de développement de l'armée russe
mais aussi rappelé le rôle de la russie
au niveau de l'art au niveau sécuritaire
dans l'arène internationale
sinon rapidement pour revenir sur
l'intervention du ministre de la défense
il a fait en début d'intervention un
parallèle entre la seconde guerre
mondiale et cette pandémie de qu'ovide
que nous traversons à l'heure actuelle
il est également revenu sur les
différentes copé coopération militaire
russe à travers le mans
mais également les menaces potentielles
qui pèsent sur la russie mais aussi sur
le reste du monde il enfin terminée sur
la nécessité de dialoguer afin entre
autres de contrôler la le déploiement
d'armements stratégiques à travers le
monde
si beaucoup antoine pour toutes les
précisions antoine gayraud vous allez
suivre évidemment ces deux jours de
conférences on y reviendra longuement
dans nos prochaines éditions entre deux
pierres ou en direct de moscou